president's plans are in the spotlight
this morning after Congress agreed to a
1 trillion dollar bipartisan Budget
agreement last night now it will fund
the government through September the
domestic spending deal comes amid new
threats from North Korea overnight the
communist country warned it will carry
out a nuclear test at any time and if
any location Margaret Brennan is outside
the White House down on the North Lawn
with the escalating tensions Margaret
good morning good morning while North
Korea said today it will continue its
nuclear weapons program in defiance of
the Trump administration's warnings this
is Kim jong-un carried out a ballistic
missile test just hours after the Trump
administration drew a hard line
we cannot let what's been going on for a
long period of years continue President
Trump
rarely minces words when speaking of
enemies but instead he expressed empathy
for Kim jong-un whose nuclear arsenal is
his top foreign policy challenge what do
you make of the North Korean leader I
have I really you know have no comment
on him people are saying is he saying I
have no idea I can tell you this a lot
of people don't like when I say it but
he was a young man of 26 or 27 when he
took over from his father when his
father died so obviously he's a pretty
smart cookie on Friday the Trump
administration formally offered Kim
jong-un the chance to negotiate an end
to the standoff to build pressure a
nuclear-powered US Navy carrier now sits
within striking distance of North Korea
President Trump's strategy appears to
Center on a mix of public flattery and
pressure on China to control Kim jong-un
I would not be happy if he does a
nuclear test I will not be happy and I
can tell you also I don't believe that
the president of China who is a very
respected man will be happy either not
happy I mean military action I don't
know I mean we'll see the president
explained that he decided to put aside
US trade disputes with China to
encourage them to influence the Supreme
Leader no I think that frankly North
Korea's may be more important than trade
trade is very important
but massive warfare with millions
potentially millions of people being
killed that as we would say Trump's
trade and this weekend President Trump
also invited Philippines president
Rodrigo Duterte to the White House
administration officials say he will
raise human rights concerns
Duterte has signed off on the
extrajudicial killings of thousands of
his own people and even personally
bragged about shooting some himself
Norah when that has created some
controversy Margaret thank you